yeah hi well
thanks for inviting me to this antonina
you know and well the first thing is you
know as you see in the title you know
you know I'll probably keep on changing
between automatability and
automatizability and I think you know
the automatizability title that nobody
likes right I think it's my fault right
because in Spanish you wouldn't say
automatic automatability so I don't know
you know you will see a variety of
titles here you know and the first thing
I want to show are some fakes you know
so
so this is Tony and I you know in San
Diego which is where we met right uh you
know this is like a collage
I didn't make it you know that was my
son you know who was working on this
pooling pictures and the math department
in the back I don't know if you remember
the building right so we met when when I
we were both a positive in at UCSD right
so Sam first told me about you don't
need that you know somebody who had
solved this really important problem you
know the lower bound and so and so on it
was coming you know to work with uh you
know Russell
So eventually we met you know I don't
remember the the exact moment and and
and we started working together you know
and what's most important for me you
know this is another thing
uh the friendship that developed you
know that was
much more important for me to be an
interviewer and so we would work
together at the math department you know
the building you saw before and then
around five you know we would go to the
to the beach you know we couldn't figure
out the exact spot right uh and run you
know and chatted you know all the way
through right so
you know that was you know
those years were probably some of the
best of my life you know and
you know the friendship was for me you
know
even though I mean the work was great
and and I love collaborating with Tony
you know like all of you you know our
conversations and activities were for me
the most important really so I'm gonna
talk about something old you know
because
[Music]
uh well it's something that I think
people are still interested in right
which is the weak automatizability I
mean people have really outstanding
results
uh on non-automatizability and there are
some open questions and I wanna
remind you guys what happened long time
ago with Tony you know basically in Iran
the three of us and you know have a
discussion I mean I talk to some people
you will see in the slides you know
anyways so let me remind you that a
prepositional
um system is something very abstract in
Cook's definition actually
the reference is not there but everybody
knows you know it's something very it's
abstract it's just a polynomial
computable compute polynomial time
computable function from strings to the
set of all tautologies right and you can
see it also as a verification procedure
that you have a pair possible proof and
formula and if despair is accepted you
know that's a proof right and you have
to have you know accepted instances for
all the tautologies basically right and
the fact that this definition is so
abstract uh has a lot to do with the
weak automatizability the way I see it
you know and you know so anyways the
first question that you know was up you
know opposed by hook and so on was you
know how big
are the sizes of
this tautologies or the reputations
right
but at some point we were very
interested in okay you know
we know that there will be a
tautologists or contradictions that will
require very long proofs right but if
the proofs of reputations are small you
know do we have could we have procedures
to find them in a reasonable time right
so this is how
This research started between the three
of us right so
um we invented this term right and this
definition right so you have a proof
system and you want to know if it's
automatizable in the sense of is there
an algorithm what no no no
different they're different versions
yeah and that's why the title was not so
much with this actually antonina came up
with this title you know I was looking
for ideas and that sort of contribution
which is a very good one you know and I
keep on saying automatizable and
automatic you know I cannot change
I actually almost emailed the staff
saying oh she probably put the star in
there as an accident you might want to
take that out no no no no no no
okay anyway so a purchase them
would be automatable well I don't even
know how to say it if there is just an
algorithm
if there is an algorithm such a you know
as you know it takes an a formula and
returns a proof be in that system okay
that's automatizable in that system in
polynomial time in the size of the
shortest P proof of that formula so that
was our first definition
but there are other you know variants
you know like was a polynomial time
automatizable like this property uh
three leg resolution has you know and
this has been discussed previously and
also we have a notion of weak automatic
and what does this mean so it means okay
and and it makes a lot of sense in a lot
of practical sense you know uh you know
you might you don't want to force you
know the the
the procedure to Output a p proof right
but maybe some other proof right so here
I have a definition of weekly
automatable
and there I mean and I will show you
several equivalences so B is weekly
automatable if there is an
well I cannot say it I'm sorry
peace weekly automatizable if there is
an automatizable proof system that
simulates B okay
and
here are some no sorry
equivalences but before I show you and
we talk about the equivalences there is
like a notion that helps understand
what's going on and it's related to this
uh abstractness of the definition of
what is a what a group system is okay so
there's this notion of uh disjoint NP
pair
so this joint and people are something
very simple you have two problems in NP
and that their intersection is empty
okay
it would be for instance graphs there
are
okay color and
you know the color ability and the um
yeah like I couldn't say that yeah click
in in Coloring right
so uh I think that it was rasporov that
came up with the idea of talking about
canonical NP pairs for a propositional
per system so what is that so a pair so
this is a pair right
and ref of p is you have a formula and
you know and a size okay and
it
so that P has a reputation of that
formula in size m
and the other element in the pair
is um sat so you have a formula and the
size and the formula is satisfiable
okay so what do we know that is
equivalent and I you know I think good
luck proves some of this Albert and I in
another paper you know several people
have been noticing these things you know
the canonical NP pairs for a
prepositional proof system being
polynomially separable is equivalent to
various Notions of weak automatizability
like the one that I was telling you
before like there is another proof
system that simulates p and that is
automatizable or you know
another notion that is that there exists
an algorithm that
for a proof system that returns proofs
you know
uh in the size of the shortest formula
it they don't need to be yes
if something it was
amazing it should be automobile and when
you put it should be audible well
I think I can only say one of this yeah
Okay so
and this equivalence equivalent is the
reason for all of this is that a proof
system is something some
it's a you know polynomial uh time
procedure basically you know
or checking whether something is
approval of a tautology or not right
so uh well here have interpolation with
Project's name but I mean interpolation
correct interpolation interpreted by
John krycek right so this is an
observation so you have uh f and g that
have
um
um it's an unsatisfiable
uh conjunction and given an assignment
for the common bar you have X variables
that are common Y and Z that are not
common
so if you give an assignment for the X
variables then either F or G is
unsatisfiable right
so
you know that gave rise to the
interpolation problem you have an
unsatisfiable formula okay and given an
assignment
Alpha to the X variables you want to
know if which part is unsatisfiable f on
G and the problem is well return zero if
it's F return one if it's G okay
so
um then we can talk about a proof system
having the interpolation
feasible interpolation right if the
interpolation problem is solvable in
polynomial time with respect to the
smallest
peer reputation of this conjunction
well
you know
well that was the first paper that we
wrote I mean we I think we use this
observation I think this observation
comes from
Russell you know and it's in our paper
saying that if p is automatizable or
actually in this case weekly automatic
automatizer also
then P has feasible interpolation right
and it's a very simple idea you know
so you suppose that P is uh
automatizable right so it then is the
size of the smallest peer refutation
uh and Alpha is an assignment of the
common variables you use the automatic
the automatization procedure on F with
Alpha and run it for polynomial number
of steps
if you get a zero I mean
then you you succeed if you get a zero
because that means that f is
unsatisfiable otherwise you write a one
you know there's a property that you
have to have here about reputations
which is if you
say for instance is satisfiable if you
put you know if you assign values to the
disease you know the reputation of f
should come from the reputation should
be embedded in the refutation of the
full formula and I don't know the name
of this property and I mean I don't
remember
what close on the restrictions yeah
something like that
okay so this is how we started you know
but you know this all come com comes
from
a paper by crycheck and Putlocker you
know because they were working on
non-feasible interpolation for extender
frege right but you know we
you know reduce the complexity of the
proof system and made the connection
with the automatizability
okay so this is you know uh everybody
knows what the fragrance system I mean
we've heard a lot about this is just a
textbook definition with the modus pawn
and some axioms you know bounded the
frege
you know you have a constant number of
alternations of ants and ORS you can put
the negations at the bottom level and
the connectives have unbounded degree
PCC it's unbounded the frege you have
threshold and parties parity connectives
and rules for them okay
so actually
what did we use so actually let me go
forward a little bit
um so we want to show that uh previous
systems and eventually systems don't
have feasible interpolation
under some cryptographic assumptions so
this is the cryptographic Assumption we
were working with
and I have been trying to remember all
the places where we've had discussions
and I think we were in Israel and I'm
not completely sure talking to money now
or is it possible or I'm making it up
and he told us about difficult man
I remember going into his office and I
think it was in in Israel
um anyways what is difficult man right
so you have Alice and Bob they both have
you know they don't I mean they have a
secret a large stick okay so we're gonna
do this first of all uh using uh um
the multiplicative group
um
zp and we have a public generator G okay
and Alice has secret a
I don't know how to point to this you
know
huh
red button I don't see a red button oh
yeah yeah okay and uh Bob has a large
secret B okay so what is it that they do
Alice
uh sends G to the a mod P okay to Bob
this is public and Bob Essence G to the
B mod P to Alice okay and now
they compute they both compute G to the
a b mod P each one of them right so they
share some information that nobody
should know okay unless this procedure
is just not secure right
so
if you do it with a product of two large
primes then
breaking diffie-hellman you know is
harder than factoring
and
anyways
so
this is what we were gonna use right so
it took
um construction sorry
uh it took constructing this conjunction
a0 here is one part A1 in the form of
the physical interpolation right so we
have variables X and Y that are common
X and Y that are common in both formulas
and non-common variables c a b and c d
okay so what is this formula say this
formula is saying that X is the same as
G to the a mod m
okay
why is g to the B mod M okay and the
last bit of G to the a mod m is zero
and the other one will say x says G to
the C Mod m
is X
G to the D mod m is y
and the last bit of G to the DC mod m is
1. right why is this a contradiction
this is a contradiction
okay so a0 and A1 is unsatisfiable since
okay this
since we know that g to the a is X
okay everything is mod M now let's just
okay so but we also they also tell us
that
um
G to the C
mod m is X so now we put G to the C we
commute these two because this is a
product
and then G to the B is y and also G to
the D is y so we get this so a to the a
b equals g to the DC
mod M right so since since these two are
equal it's not possible that the last
bit or whatever is one
and zero okay
so this was a lot of work because we had
two
encode all this arithmetic improve all
kinds of properties
etc etc right
and um
well
we've got the non-fusible interpolation
under this cryptographic assumption
uh also no system that simulates them
has the physical interpolation so this
systems are not automatizable or weakly
automatizable
and then
we wanted to get lower proof systems and
we got a weaker result for AC 0 fege
okay so if we go back to this you know
so
um Craig doesn't have physical
interpolation until Factory unless
factoring is solvable in polynomial time
and for this one unless factoring can be
computed in some exponential time so the
result is weaker because basically what
we do is like uh
um
you know it's like we work with uh poly
log Fannin thresholds and connectives in
tc0 and simulate that in ac0 pregase so
we do some kind of weak simulation
of all the work that we've done with the
tc03 okay so that is a lot of proving
you know
all these properties and eventually we
get that this is your favorite is not
automatizable or weakly automatizable
under you know this not a strong
um
conjecture right
so you know this is the state of the
situation at this point as far as I know
right
so if we think about non-automatizable
systems you know under assumptions you
know
uh well there's this you know great
results that have appeared lately you
know about resolution risque
no style and such and polynomial
calculus cutting planes surely Adams
I've heard that some people have sold
this you know
oh okay so it's not clear okay you I
have a question mark because I wasn't
sure you know so is this fine
okay fine and as far as I know uh it's
open for some of squares really open
okay
and
okay it's not true that okay there are
no more results on weak automatizability
I I will show you more but it's not
clear that the assumptions are strong we
will see it now okay but so far this is
what was done in the 90s right okay
so I wanted to have a little discussion
of what else do I know about this and
you know I mean this is
through conversations with Albert and
Pavel you know
and uh
okay so there are three papers and Tony
is involved in one of them again you
know that relates okay so basically the
idea is to look for
um problems that you think that are in
NP intersection co-mp and not likely to
be in B right
like what we did with the factoring and
the cryptography
and uh so there's this uh games graph
games okay several of them right and uh
we know that deciding whether a player
has a winning strategy is an NP
intersection going B
and so what people did is show that for
instance uh if depth we pray or you know
very low depth
It's weekly automatizable then this uh
games can be decided in polynomial time
right so
people expect that they will not be
decidable in polynomial time you
wouldn't expect this load that phrase to
be weakly automatizable
it is not clear what you know will come
out of this because you know there are
so positive polynomial time algorithms
for solving party games right
so I don't know I don't I don't know you
know uh
is that
is the best
simple stochastic
well I don't know I mean I bought this
through Pavel actually he's the one who
found the newspaper and others that have
improved on this and they have quasi
polynomial time algorithms for pirate
games and I've looked through you know I
mean I've done a search
and I couldn't find quasi polynomial
time or polynomial time uh Solutions you
know for deciding winning strategies uh
for the other games right so I haven't
found that but yeah I see other game
special cases of parody games uh oh it's
the other way around okay right sorry so
you know I wanted to mention this you
know also because it's you know Tony's
work too yeah it's just hard to say that
this was a polynomial time algorithm
after those papers I don't know yeah
actually
I suppose you know 2017 for the collude
the the last papers from 2017. so it's
pretty good yeah actually yeah
it was the best paper in stock
right right no I should have said that
you know and I looked at the dates and
everything but I had I had forgot I mean
I forgot
okay but I wanted to mention this
because they're very interesting results
but we don't know you know whether they
will take us somewhere or not right
so uh this is some silly dead end right
okay so people have talked about
automatizability here talking I mean and
they have mentioned you know such and
such proof is automatizable because they
were thinking in terms of if some
algebraic proof system uh
has an algorithm you know that can find
um
reputations of the you know using the
degree rather than the size right so
here we're working with the size right
and so for instance you know can we use
any of the so this is a silly no okay
but I'm just gonna mention it anyways so
for instance for resolution I mean could
any of these procedures you know for
surely Adams some of squares or
polynomial calculus automatized
resolution
in their sense of the size the the
answer is no
why not you know it all goes back to
that
um
over our
yeah so they ordered to the other in
principle right so we have uh um a
contradiction right that has uh
that requires
um High
um
with you know like square root of the
number of the size right but it has
small reputations in resolution so the
natural question is what happens when
you look at this uh contradiction in in
for instance polynomial calculus
whatever right so people have looked at
that you know like Nikola Massimo and
rodentin
and they've seen that this all the
ordering principle also requires pretty
high degree for various other algebraic
systems so we know those procedures are
not gonna automatize resolution I mean
this I wanted just to mention this
observation basically right
um what else
well there's this system right which is
press K what do we have it's like
resolution but we can have Conjuring
inside our closers we can have
conjunctions you know of up to K
literals right
so this is a clause a rescue Clause
where your conjunctions are at most of
size K and these are the rules of
inference you can do weakening you can
do introduction of the conjunction right
so you have ARL b or this conjunction
and it is less than k then you can
conclude this okay
and you can do some form of cut well
actually it's a cat and you have a or
this conjunction and then you have b or
not each one of this then you can derive
a or b okay that's the system and
um
we worked uh on this you know with
Albert
a long time ago right uh and we use this
reflection principle which is different
I mean again you know the reflection
principle has been discussed here in a
very different sense than what we used
it for right I don't know I mean I think
Pavel and maybe Pavel and John were the
first ones to Define this reflection
principle right
uh and it says okay so you have the form
of interpolation in this formula
you have XC and X Y variables and sat
and M means that x encodes uh
formula of n liter no n variables and M
Clauses and z and go just as its fine
assignment and on the other one on the
other side the ref
says that y encode a refutation of X of
size s and you have n and M for number
of variables and number of Clauses okay
so clearly this formula is unsatisfiable
people good luck has this theorem that
if the reflection principle has
polynomial side reputations
you know the polynomial uh okay so if
the reflection principle has polynomial
side reputations
in a group system that has physical
interpolation
okay just a second I'm saying it wrong
the reflection principle of some proof
system okay has a polynomial side
reputation in a physical in a system
that has visible interpolation then this
proof system is weakly automatizable and
the reason is just that you can separate
the
the NP player the canonical MP there for
um for that proof system basically right
so that was interesting for us right so
one of the things that we did is I would
proved that
verse 2 further reflection principle of
our solution right
so we had this equivalences not all of
them most of them and maybe none of them
require that case a constant but
basically
we know that resolution is weakly
automatizable if press 2 for instance
has feasible interpolation right because
okay we have footage theorem that if you
have the uh the reflection principle
full resolution has polynomial side
reputation in a system that has visible
interpolation then you can quickly
automatize resolution right so
it would be interesting to know and many
people think that this is not going to
be true whether price 2 for instance has
visible interpolation right
and uh you know even put like bootleg
things that this is not going to be true
um Okay so
well
what do we know about feasible
interpolation and rest too you know
uh Esteban Galaxy and Messner showed
that three likrest who has monotone
feasible interpolation
but rest too
non-trail-like doesn't have monotone
feasible interpolation
and then okay so let me go back just a
second
to putlock's theorem Okay so
figure out say for instance uh I mean to
conclude you know that resolution would
be working automatizable which many
people think that that could not be true
you would need a system that would prove
the reflection principle
and would have visible interpolation and
some other conditions like the close
closure under
pressure
restrictions restrictions right okay so
first two it would be interesting to
know if rest2 has the feasible
interpolation property because it proves
the reflection principle but the thing
is okay well we know many proof systems
uh that have visible interpolation or
monotone physical interpolation but they
prove the reflection principle of
resolution for instance
okay so this is what I wanted to you
know discuss a little bit here
well
um cutting planes has monotonefeasible
interpolation
but uh requires exponential size
reputations of the reflection principle
okay and this is a result by adult again
uh but this other systems you know like
Shirley Adams
um has monotone visible interpolation
polynomial calculus also sum of squares
seem to have feasible interpolation to
shape lover Schreiber you know Etc but
we don't know anything as far as far as
I know about whether they can prove say
the reflection principle for resolution
right
but it's an open question
so now oops these are not fakes right
so you know I'm really happy you know I
mean I was into this technical thing and
I forgot you know that we were
celebrating
you know so we're back to working
together
uh back to having fun together chatting
conversations you know
and uh I'm really happy to be
celebrating you know your birthday and
above all your friendship you know
and
it's so important for me you know
and I hope we continue you know and uh
you know and I and we can have more
pictures not fakes right
of us you know working and having fun
together conversation sharing our lives
Etc
all right
uh we're running a bit behind schedule
so uh I guess we'll take questions to
the break and I'll let's say we
reconvene at 11 50 so in 20 minutes